hello everyone and welcome to the match
you've all been waiting for it's the
1971 candidates fun the finals of the
1971 candidates Robert James Fisher
versus Tigran were town which petrosyan
definitely a clash of titans but before
we check it out we do have a photo
challenge it's not so much of a photo
challenge because if you follow my
instructions you will realize that it's
not actually a photo challenge so I will
ask you who is the person in the photo
here but the thing is next there she's a
singer from Chile
you got the Prima and if you follow the
link in the description below you will
you will be led to a song now I don't
usually promote songs on this channel
but she wrote a song about former world
chess champion josé raúl capablanca
and I thought you know you guys should
know about it and it's not every day
that someone writes a song about was a
role capablanca even though yes he was a
world chess champion and he was a fairly
handsome guy so you know you think you
know people write songs about him all
the time but you know the reality is
they don't and it's it's a very nice
song I thought you'd enjoy it but the
the real challenge is the song is about
is about one of his games so try to
figure out which game the song is
referring to so there we have it that's
the challenge now back to our game let's
check out some of the photos from this
matchup here not of the highest quality
but I'm sure you will appreciate it
fisher arrived to to buenos aires where
he shakes hands with Tigran Petrosian
before the match and here we have a nice
photo before the match started there you
have it
Petros in posing for the photo as
Petrosyan always poses for the photo
that's something you can if you google
TV Tigran Petrosian Tigran Martin which
but Rosen and check out his photos you
will see that he's always posing for a
photo that's that's the kind of guy even
petrosyan was so about this match like
we said we started this journey with the
19:17 Palma de Majorca intra zonal
tournament which happened some ten
months ago prior to this match
so the intro zone 1970 palma de mer
painters onal was in November of 1970
and now we are in September 1971 so ten
months have passed since fish since
Fischer started this
piggy journey and as you know after you
know crossing the field in palma de
mallorca then he defeated mark time on
of six to zero then he defeated then
Larsen six to zero so basically Fischer
won 19 of his last games that he played
in a row but you know Tigran Petrosian
also out of the 42 games he played he
only lost two so it's not that he wants
so much games but you can see that it's
very hard to beat Tigran Petrosian
and although okay he's the semi-final
match versus Viktor Korchnoi was really
really a close call he only won one game
against victor question and that was
enough to conclude the match so although
you know we can agree that a former
world champion Tigran Petrosian is the
strongest of Fischer's opponents you
know he proves it by being in the finals
but also when you hear Tigran Petrosian
you know you have the utmost respect for
the guy so I'm sure you'll enjoy this
game this is the first game of their
match where Petrosyan actually goes on
an all-out attack against Fischer you
know he doesn't go with his usual style
but rather prepares a very nice novelty
in one of Fischer's favorite lines of
the Sicilian so without further ado
Fischer sits at the board and he opens
with well what else he for petrosyan
plays c5 now yesterday I believe I
posted the game Fischer played against
Petrosyan it was the match USSR versus
the rest of the world so if you've seen
that game you use you've seen how
Fischer demolished him and that's the
last game to have them played before
meeting here so petrosyan changes his
approach he goes for the Sicilian I will
have Knight to f3 d6 d4 C capture son d4
Knight captures knife to c6
and now after Petrosyan chooses the time
now no variation we have Knights the b5
Fischer follows the same path he played
against the marked amount of in Game six
of their match so we have
d6 Bishop to f4 and now II five Bishop
back to e3 and now Knight to f6 so at
the same move order as Fischer head
against time on off so we I'm just gonna
mention it once more this is the
position
the famous game Murphy vs. Anderson
where Anderson post f5 and then after
night c3f for Murphy proceeded with
Knight d5 and you know achieved the
great brilliance against Anderson and
took his hooking for a nice walk now you
might have seen it on my channel if you
haven't I will put a link to it in the
description below
you know just if you want to further
increase your vast knowledge but okay
Knight to f6 same in same as in the game
against mark the amount of brush up to
g5 and now eat a bunch of three six
nights III a six night we have a bunch
of captors on f6g captors on f6 and the
knife to a3 so this is the exact same
position Fischer had on the board
against marked a monofin their
candidates match and here you have a you
know a lot of lines were familiar in
those days for example Knights the d4 is
the moved amount of played onion fissure
and also a couple of years before that
also neither tried this against Fischer
and also it's there is a known game
between taimanov and Karpov were teaming
have also tried this not night before
but rather nighty seven against Karpov
and the Karpov won this game so a lot of
things you know a lot of moves were
tried in this position but the move
Petrosyan played was never played in
this position well perhaps it was but
not in high competition so people would
know about it
Allah you know it was not in the
database although in those days there
wasn't like a digital database but well
you know what I mean Petrosyan played d5
and this is a very interesting concept
now I'm sure a lot of players thought
about this move you know before because
it's a well known idea if you can push
d5 and you're playing the Sicilian and
white can't take advantage of it then
you're definitely doing okay so what
what do you do here okay Fischer play
ECAD 475 the strongest reply and now we
have Bishop captures on a3 so there are
a couple of things you can decide to do
here so what do you do you have to
capture the bishop if you try some wild
idea like D captures on e6 you're gonna
lose the bishop capture some d2 but it's
not at all clear like immediately how do
you lose for example a captures on f7
would check you don't capture
looking to a fate and now Knight to e4
you try to give up this rook but black
isn't interested black would go Queen to
a5 check now you have to block nice to
d2 and then you get rook to b8 and now
you see the problem if you try and save
the rook then Bishop comes here and
there's no saving the night or even even
you don't even have to pin it you can
simply play rook captures and now it's
game over black one because if you
capture them bishops eatery wins the
Queen on the other hand after this rope
to d8 move if you try something like
what not dead but let's say Bishop to d3
but has this very simple efore move
which now creates a nice pin the knight
can capture because it's pinned if you
capture with the bishop then you get the
same idea rook captures and e2 so here
white would be without a choice and you
would simply let's say capture the rook
Knight captures and then play Bishop
back and you grab the piece and you are
winning here so it's a you have to
prepare this but I'm sure Fischer at
some point thoroughly analyzed this
position I don't think d5 was I like a
move he never thought about it could
happen in this position so okay he
played B captors on a3 we have Queen to
a5 now a very nice move these pieces are
still under attack but Queen captures on
c3 would come with tempo so okay Queen
to d2 and here petrosyan castles Queen
side now again you cannot capture here
because now of course again you would
lose the Queen so a very rich position
happened here we have Bishop to c4 by
Fischer he prepares to Castle kingside
and now comes Luke H to g8 so now you
can see that
Petrosyan really plays a beautiful chess
here very active you know his pieces are
very active he has a semi-open G file
and here a fetcher plays rook to d1 he
increases the protection of his deep on
and still okay he still can't capture
anything but he's just waiting to see
what what petrosyan will do and here he
invites petrosyan to capture on g2 and
although it seems like the the best idea
for some reason
Petrosyan isn't interested in the
for example if rook captures on g2 it's
not
it seems that Petrosyan didn't analyze
it all the way to here because now after
94 offering a queen trade of course
black will decline now you offer to
trade Queens yet again and now after
Queen captures F captures and this
Bishop to g4 move you can see that
Petrosyan now untangles and still
Fischer will not be able to capture here
because of this rook to d1 threat and
after you move rook captures you can't
capture with the King because of Bishop
to f3 Knight would have to capture and
then after 97 you can see that now
always well for black here but still so
it's hard to make a call like this he
perhaps he didn't enjoy this position to
play this position against Fischer okay
he keeps all the tension on the board he
plays at Bishop f5 we have Bishop to d3
challenging the Bishop Bishop captures
Queen captures and now comes Knight to
d4 so okay still everything is on the
board and here Fischer castles a very
nice move showing that he's not afraid
of the of the semi open G file here King
to b8 a very important move because now
this is actually an attacking move well
it's a defending move but also an
attacking move i Fischer is not careful
here and for example play something like
h3 do you see how black wins the game
here instantly you know feel free to
pause the video and try to find it it's
a very nice idea one you can often use
your own in your own games so for those
of you who have found that
congratulations you are an excellent
player and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show
Queen captures in c3 a temporary Queen
sacrifice after white accepts 90 to
check simply picks up the Queen and it's
a lower white black is up a piece and
winning the game so okay
after King to b8 Petrosyan prepares this
and now Fischer goes King to h1 not
allowing 92 to come with check so K
Queen captures on a3 here
Petrosyan could have continued with
ideas like rook to g6 this would have
probably been best pile you know try to
double up on the G file and then try
pushing the H pawn to open up
fishers kingside but here instead he
goes for this Queen captures on a three
move and this allows Fischer some
counter play so here fish pushes f4 f4
is a very nice idea because it allows
the both rooks to come into the fence of
the of the g2 pawn and also attacks
Petrosyan Center okay rook the c8
attacking Fisher's knight on c3 and now
Fischer has to move the knight Knight to
e4 offer a queen trade and here again
you have to see what what do you want to
do here do you want to trade Queens or
do you want to play something like Queen
captures on a - Queen captures on a - is
very interesting because now I have two
rook to d2 you go into this variation
rook captures rook captures Queen
captures Queen captures Knight captures
and now Knight captures on f6
threatening the rock on g8 rook moves
and now pawn captures on e5 and you
would have this position where the
material on the board is equal but
Fischer's position with the two central
pawns already on the fifth leg will be
will be somewhat better and these bones
are very weak you can see that Fischer
has to pawn islands and Petrosyan would
have three pawn islands so not something
you want to do so instead fit Rosen
traits Queens here queen capture son b3c
capture some d3 and the now rook to c2
again with a lot of pressure against the
fish or skiing side rook to d2 defending
the G - pond and also defending the a to
pawn rook captures Knight captures and
here
f5 was played I move like for example
rook to d8 going after the pawn
immediately would be met with captures
on e5 captures on e5 and now captures on
f7
here h5 not allow me to capture but look
to h7 Rob captures the rook captures on
h5 and here a Fischer would be up upon
but also he would have to connected pass
pawns on the Kings side so okay after 92
we have f5 petrosyan tries this idea
sorry about that
we have F captures on e5 and now rook to
e8 attacking d5 pawn rook to e1 Fischer
defense the pawn and now comes night to
see to attack in Fishers rook and here
after rook to e2 Petrosyan repeats rook
to the Knights the d4
we have looked to e3 and
night to see to hear petrosyan would
very much enjoy a draw and I believe he
even offered the draw here but Fisher
declined it
and he played rook to h3 and it's very
important to know that
Petrosyan took really really a lot of
time for for most of his moves they say
that he even took 25 minutes for some
moves so Fisher was a really really a
heron clock here and they still needed
to make 10 more moves to reach time
control so okay but rosen place rook
captures an e5 Fisher finds a very nice
way how to continue the struggle and now
Knight to f3 a very important move
guarding d1 square from from checkmate
and also preparing enough to capture on
h7 rook captures on d5 and now rope
characters on h7 rook captors on d3 and
now h4 official create some breathing
room for the king now the knight can
move and also he can start pushing his
own passport and because now you can see
that it's actually Petrosyan who is up
upon but Fischer is the one that has the
outside passport and of course when you
have a past point you have to push it
because pass pawns and must be pushed oh
ok nice the e3 now by Petrosyan he wants
to now grab the a to pawn and try to
start pushing his own Queen side points
you can't really play route to d7 to
protect the f7 pawn because the f7 pawn
is pretty much worthless here Fischer
will simply push h5 and say okay you now
have a rook guarding the useless f7 pawn
I'm just gonna push my own passed pawn
to victory
so after h4 nights to e3 was played we
have rook captures on f7 rook to d1
check King to h2 and now Luke - a - ok
Fischer pushes h5 and here I move like
rook captures and a 2 would have been
best for Petrosyan and then after
because the geophone is threatened night
to h5 comes defending and now rook to a5
and this would have been the best choice
because now h6 isn't possible because
Knight to g4 check would pick up the
pawn but like we said petrosyan was very
low on time and here he played f4
he decided to sacrifice this pawn and he
thought that he would be able to hold
this but that
that couldn't be farther from the from
the truth Fisher simply captured upon
rook captures on it for we have rook a
person a to now threatening the G to
pawn and here he probably thought that
okay if you push h6 then I'm just gonna
capture on G to King h3 rubgy 8h 7 roof
h8 okay my rook is passive but I'm
defending here let's say Knight g5
defending the pawn and now a5 b5 is
coming a4 is coming
Petrosyan would have a passive rook but
he would also start pushing his own
Queen side pawns probably due to the
time trouble this was petrosian's idea
but Fischer plays rook to e4 and now
you're you're in a lot of trouble here
what do you do here now you can no
longer play rook captures on g3 on g2
because of after king h3 your rook is
under attack and the night so if you
move the knight you lose the rook and if
you don't do anything simply rook
captures night you would lose a piece
here you would have to move and after
rook to e2 defending the knight now you
would get h6 and you would have this
funny rook defending your funny night
but okay it's still not all that clear
what you do here after this rook to e4
move if you try rook to a5 immediately
you could still kind of continue the
struggle but not really you lose the
night here and then after rook captures
on h5 wood checking to g3 is coming and
here you could hope that your two
connected passed pawns on the Queen side
are you know substitution enough for for
a whole piece but still white would be
better here and the most likely Windus
but okay after this Knight captures
energy to move after this move Petra
simply denied captures in g2 but it's
still not enough
pressure plate King to g3 now getting
out of any unnecessary discoveries
rock to a5 was played and here of course
Fischer did not capture the night if
King captures the new rule captures on
h5 you have zero points now as white and
two two connected passed pawns on the
Queen side will be enough compensation
for the piece so you white would not be
able to win this even though his upper
piece so after this rook - if I move
Fischer simply played 95 and now in this
position Petros and resigned to the game
because there is nothing he can do
this point is gonna be promoted to a
queen but even worse than that the
knight is trapped the knight has nowhere
to go the rook and King are nicely
guarding all of the squares the knight
can jump too so there's really nothing
to do here anymore well of course if you
if you try and protect the night and
then simply h6 and again you have a
funny rook guarding a funny night so
yeah after Knight to e5 this is move 40
so petrosyan did didn't even reach time
control here Fischer played Knight to e5
and here it's very important to say that
Petrosyan had a couple of seconds on the
clock and I don't know if his clock time
on the clock right after or if he
resigned with only a couple of seconds
on the clock but Fisher had over over
half an hour on his clock in this
position so yeah fish were played 95 on
the 40th move and Petrosyan resigned the
game so Fisher continues his legendary
streak making this his 20th the victory
in a row and it couldn't be greater
achieving his 20th the victory in a row
against top grandmasters against the
former world champion such as Tigran
Petrosian sure that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it and you know hope you're
enjoying the Bobby Fischer series so far
it's very interesting I was contacted by
a subscriber of mine who works in a
theater in Buenos Aires where this match
took place and he said that he will send
me some photos so I saved I will try to
show you some of the photos of the place
where they played and try to compare it
with you know the older photos so you
can see the comparison in some other
videos of this match so I would like to
thank you James nor would I be no-hit
TPM de Graaff and Mario and see no Sara
Weston and the Georgian it is for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check too on my
previous video see our thing called for
watching and I will see you soon
hopefully with another interesting video
and do check out the song about Jose
role Capablanca in the description below
and try to figure out from which game
the song is which game the song refers
to yeah thank you all and I'll see you
soon